en soixante dix ans de règne elizabeth
ii a connu neuf présidents français en
1957 c'est sa première visite officielle
en france en tant que souveraine et le
président rené coty l'attend à
l'aéroport après soleil de printemps
éclairé la rencontre à orly de sa
majesté elizabeth 2 et du président coty
c'est le début d'une histoire d'amour
diplomatiques entre les deux pays je
suis profondément ému
ainsi que mon mari se montre généreux
accueil et nous voulons qu'ils ont vu
tout coeur merci trois ans plus tard
c'est la reine qui reçoit le général de
gaulle est reçu en grande pompe en
angleterre avec tout le faste royal
c'est aujourd'hui un cortège de carros
et de cavaliers à panache qui a conduit
le président de gaulle au milieu des
acclamations d'une foule généralement
réservées jusqu'à buckingham palace la
reine a pour le général en profond
respect mais leur histoire c'est du je
t'aime moi non plus car il s'oppose à
l'entrée de la grande bretagne dans le
marché commun européen
son successeur georges pompidou
corrigera cela le président de la
république prenant la souveraine par le
bras armé et le geste d'amitié va
l'amener vers le salon pour les discours
d'accueil un geste d'amitié même si
selon le protocole on ne touche pas la
reine le prochain sur la liste à tenter
de la séduire c'est valéry giscard
d'estaing la france et la
grande-bretagne sont comme un couple
d'amoureux passionnés qui vivent un
drame perpétuelle de rupture et de
retrouvailles
avec françois mitterrand c'est une belle
amitié et c'est la reine qui résume le
mieux ce nouveau duo franco-britannique
la tradition anglo saxonne
est un peu à la tradition latine en
europe ce que l'huile est au vinaigre il
faut les deux pour faire la sauce entre
eux la salade est plutôt bien
assaisonner et en 1994 il inaugure
ensemble le tunnel sous la manche
deux ans plus tard c'est le président
jacques chirac qui comme le général de
gaulle et reçus royalement à londres
carros tradition fast jacques chirac en
frac n'a pas boudé son plaisir ensemble
il fête le centenaire de l'entente
cordiale un texte signé en 1904 pour
mettre fin aux rivalités coloniales la
durée la profondeur et la diversité de
nos liens l'emportent à l'évidence sur
nos divergences une relation qui survit
à toutes les divergences car avec la
reine les présidents français ont fait
de leur mieux pour lui plaire pour elle
on choisit des rose assorti à sa robe
pour elle le président lui même est prêt
à tous les efforts
70 ans que tous les présidents français
sont prêts à tous les efforts pour
elizabeth 2
[Musique]